i love you for that
ruby
what am i going to do i don't care what
you find in the trash i do all the time
dawg but i find the best [ __ ] dog
there's a [ __ ] little ape [ __ ] over
my [ __ ] you know that but it's okay
because um
i believe that like this
[Applause]
if you don't do it like that in the
situation that we're in
you'd go crazy because i went crazy
already are you crazy
not yet because i got a lot of fruit we
okay you hear me and i said [ __ ] you
broke
like that
a long time ago i told her
what happened to your nose
i don't know sir but it's it's not bad
today it's just fine
what is it i don't know i might be a i
might be a a a spider in there or
something underneath
but i went to my friend's house the
other day and i said oh my
god and i looked to the right and i said
oh he man's here we are
and we didn't have he-man there he would
have been [ __ ] for real long
i can't press on national tv excuse me
sir
yes sir okay so let's get back to the
boat i just played with you on that f
word you know oh yeah because we don't
use it only if we tell them
the daily journey sets the day
your box is
stern
that's a good one
she's 75.2 percent now
we're going all that
and who's the horse gonna run
rhino
rhino's gonna run ryder's gonna win he
said my dad
on the thor
barcode
he says he's gonna win are you betting
on the horses i'll check we're betting
on horses right now yeah
little play
can make your day play daily three oh
it's a lottery ticket uh yeah all day
long
now if you you you you see that they're
cast or cast they have to write barcode
cached
but if they're not then sometimes you
got that winning prize you never know
because i got a whole bunch in there
right now winners but yeah okay so
perka boys
with the chinese little bunny hat yeah
it's a bunny hat but i don't know his
ears are see laffy don't like it so we
tell them fluff it up boy i see you
don't want to so what's up come on
floppy
oh there goes laffy yay lobby
good boy laffy
okay ready get okay
loppy
he only likes that one
it don't work on this ruby you keep
yourself entertained oh all day long
they do it they do it for me though they
really doing right hold on now let's see
if we get his sugar working today
because abba is one of those kinds that
and you you have a family somewhere
i don't know
but my mother said and my dad said we
found shook
so i shook the life
in a [ __ ] tomb way down where they
found him way down
we coming up dog
nobody i'm down bring those boys up no
matter what
my boys i ride for the ride dog
and if my heart pumps through them
i swear i'm coming to get them no matter
if it's in a grave
whatever lofty
shut up loppy okay laffy says you're
gonna go
so
that's where we're at with twinkle toes
today because
real hands the hell's angel [ __ ]
i just tell noah to get off the boat for
a minute
and he had to and it brought my heart
because ruby how many years you've been
down here
excuse bro and it bro i love my brother
though don't you get that [ __ ] dandy
he's coming back in like
he'd be on the board again
because he's better than horn right now
and i can't
no he's not
we just looked at each other and he said
what he said i said what i said and we
said like that
because when you're riding that red car
maybe that's my my heartbeat
because i feel that going not getting
all over through my organ you hear me
right now i do really
i don't know
whatever it is is good [ __ ] though you
know what i'm saying maybe i just need
that little pumper
come up right
i don't know what they're trying to say
but what i'm saying is i love
my people
in america a lot of them
some are wrong some are right who are
you people
all different kinds
all different kinds of walks
i mean i'm talking about
i had a good teacher when he was brain
in my brain
that's what it is
because when he told me i could walk on
water i don't know i don't think i can
walk harder because i've tried
i'm pretty sure i couldn't make it off
with that thing that crushed out
we'll make it really do you have
memories of your childhood
yeah what are you doing
what do you remember
like
the best one in childhood memories is i
was always on skates i skate up down the
street all around no matter what i'm
skating
if i'm not skating i'm in the pool
if i'm not in the pool i'm doing
something
boys girls club's telling me i got to go
to the pacific aquarium and i'll go to
pacific aquarium we go look at some [ __ ]
but whenever the
lights go out
and you see sucker fishes on fish
i don't know
synthetic
because tadpoles are real
you know they really are
i like it
but then i used to go to
where is that [ __ ] what was that
called
newport bay
in the back bay it was called
some [ __ ]
and i swear
they had it netted off and [ __ ] i'd say
that the [ __ ] shark was coming out no
matter my mind is on the water it goes a
whole different way
so like
my dad said get out of the pool
shark's gonna get you
you're right
but knowingly i really think that
[ __ ]
that thing yet sea world you know that
that one shark that's real nice and [ __ ]
she ain't nice that her well oh she
coming after you
if you don't get your ass up out of that
water
and she spits back we did oh girl
so you better swim wherever you got to
go because he coming girl you gotta get
the [ __ ] up out of that pool you hear me
that's how i i do
so then i seen piranhas when i was five
or six
what what constitutes a good day for you
here in skid row so i've seen everything
in the world was it was a good day for
ruby
a good day is uh
i don't know right now because this is
for little paw
i feel this one it's good ball what's
gonna happen this one under here my
chinese guy said
it's under here my mom tells me it's
under here
i say it's in that tub what's a bad day
look like
a bad day is hell
if i see you i'm happy that day no
matter what because
[ __ ] that goes on in america is [ __ ]
the demons that you have probably seen i
have never i love you
i don't give a [ __ ] i know they're on
this earth because i seen the dude i
they said they captured him and he is
[ __ ] walking dead yesterday
with nostrils coming out
younger
it was hip
what the [ __ ] do i say about that [ __ ]
and then about
i thought the goddamn devil had us
blinded sorry brother
you know
but then i look at that [ __ ]
monkey and he's really [ __ ] walking
i said
he just kept on going like nothing but
he's blue as cold as ice and [ __ ] in
the tomb for real
i don't know what else to [ __ ] do
now i don't know about that cinema
but i know this one tell me like that
he's a stir
and when a stir
tells me
75.2
i'll go ride that [ __ ] you always come
in with little treasures from the trash
yeah but it's midday right
wait what's the best thing you've ever
found in the
in the dumpsters
everything
i've seen the diamond i don't remember
it i think it was purple
this [ __ ] thing was the size of my
little
that's right but then i get [ __ ] like
this
give diamond earrings yeah so
like what the [ __ ] is that [ __ ]
but when you get it you take it
right there to the heat and put it stick
it right through that hole
because
half
have don't ever pierce their ears
i'm sorry don't ever pierce your ears
did you pierce your ears i did
when you would not want to
i think you just did just now i was
older now you look
yeah my mom made me wait
but
some get it at birth
i think it's the piercings
or they say it's the ink
that we were using
rue you you haven't had covet have you
yeah
i do i don't know i still got i don't
know they say i'm the host i'm not
though
there's no way in hell because the host
is the host's host
it's a hoax
called what do you ever get sick
no
i've always been that kid nobody down
here gets sick yeah
yeah we don't
you don't said were those kids you hear
me when they had to buy those guys and
those guys went in to buy us and they
said you can't have that ride
and they got a ticket to ride that train
and what do you say
oh board
and they say
christmas
and they jump on that tread and he said
yeah we got it
oh yeah we got it that one
oh we got it that's all i need to see
you know
now
[ __ ] like that and the mannequin
hollywood
now that's my car
hollywood hollywood come get me
hollywood
that's my mannequin
you can't tell me
that black guy and that white guy don't
love each other
i don't care what you tell me
i know
so like
how about
ruby i can't tell if you're crazy or not
because you're you're happy every day
every day i see you
you're no i'm really not some days
inside i cry
some days to look at this pathetic [ __ ]
going on do they understand what i say
what upsets you because
the muscles and everything that i put
into
i don't get it
i don't need to get it
all that i know is that i'm okay
in my heart
i ride
and whenever they gave me that honor
when they basing me up that day
and they told me that a girl could be
amazing and my dad's gonna give me that
key from around the world
and then that little
alabama queen came through that desert
that day and she said she's here from
europe and she gonna tell me the euro
for the day
and
everything else that i've learned in my
lifetime i don't understand
do you understand
i know
don't get me wrong i know
is it possible
it's fascinating
we're living through this [ __ ] dog
how i grant you your honor dog because
i didn't think
until i see it set to go
just like that
i said that's my brother
that's the most godly [ __ ] on
the earth he ain't got no [ __ ]
dude
he's the
type
so i had to hear her and i loved you
since that day
so then he'd tell me like that
and i never did that until right now
with you
now
if you were wrong and i was right and i
was wrong and you were right
i promised you i'd die for you
i'll tell jesus take me away and put me
wherever you have to
for my person to live
because they have fought so hard for me
in america
people like you
that went so far to go through every gym
and
he said he did it
when that [ __ ] hindu came out and
told me that he did that
i said you got a little log stop see ya
so i need to hear sir
said are we going to be okay he said
yeah
i said on this planet
i don't know
maybe they'll have to move us to another
club we don't know yet
whatever it is they got [ __ ] to it
because when i seen star trek
star trek had all those [ __ ] robots
in a line i mean
from here to timbuktu you can't see [ __ ]
at the desert and it's [ __ ] full of
robots we alright
you hear me brother
because the men on the spirit has to
make it like that
but i think these kids are better than
that
so they're teaching them like
new psychology
and i like it
and this little kid he'll come to me
like
[ __ ] like that
i told no dog
me
[Music]
no you know what i said
we know
whatever he said
whatever whatever spaceships faster and
i give you all keys to go
do your thing and do your chewbuck and
but look at this what i found just a
[ __ ]
freak me out today dawg
i'm gonna bring you this
this this is what i had to cover bring
this [ __ ] [ __ ] because you're kind
and say they they for you look
nail polish
it's not my color
that's for you today dog thank you now
when they tell me [ __ ] like that
we're gonna ride that ship dog because
if i'm stupid enough not to
we gotta have a problem
so
then it tells me like this
what did you find
what is that what is that
all right that
contents
health fight spread of germs flu viruses
sanitizing uh-huh you can probably get
high-end
fungus flour mold mildew all of it
it says the ingredient 100
99
total
ingredients it's just in a bottle
when i seen that
and stop working on me we all right
we're going to be okay because i didn't
go spray that [ __ ] thing no
matter how i
ruby do you have any health problems at
all
i used to have asthma
nobody i mean since you've been on skid
row okay so
i heard that people could sleep for
four hours
without taking a breath
i'm not sure about that four hours
that's good [ __ ] because
they used to do sleep apnea tests on
who would breathe longer than the other
one
way back in the days
i don't understand
i don't know
i don't know where i come from really
my mom said she did mom she was my aunt
dc's daughter
not fake
aunt dc is my mama's mom
i said whatever you said mom
now what i've seen
i don't know
we're all right
and if you would be
our sister brother that we say we are
like in a hood status
i got you hood
i told you when they did they took you
down there and i said what the [ __ ] you
do this jim you get
i wasn't taking no for an answer
there was no way in goddamn [ __ ]
kingdom i was gonna let you get bounded
i don't care if it is your snake my
snake
what in the [ __ ] had you down there
i love you skip
cause i heard that giant
he's mighty big
an elephant stampede could take down the
world
now the gorillas i think they got
covered
when i see those [ __ ] come over
that embankment
and i have dreams like this
trucks
taking this
line of gorillas
never stopped until i woke up
i think
but then i said my god when i see
they've come over that san bernardino
where those boys were buried and i said
you're going to open your eye for me
again
they told me no how the [ __ ] you make me
make me feel you hear me
i gotta go
no baby not
you'll be okay
okay so you're amazing ruby you're
amazing to me and all i say is
whatever you say dog i got to you
and it's not about the money
it's about your mind
and how
how i know you are as a [ __ ] all of it
you hear me
no matter what your kids do
i know you
that's all i need to know
and you're a wonderful person
and i think you're amazing
and that's what i tell america
because without you
i would have nothing
because you were a smarter man
you were a little bit before me
but you had it right on for women
and when you have it on for women and
women can't help themselves
and they're evil as [ __ ]
i love your wicked tree
because my witch is a wicked witch of
the west
yours is maybe the east
we're gonna open those doors
ruby
you hear me i don't i don't i hear you
but i don't understand you yeah i love
you for that
so let's go like this
for america one more time
who that
you got to fix your other ear
yes sir
thank you very much you're welcome very
much
you